HAVE TO WAIT.
AS YOU MENTIONED, A BIG NIGHT
FOR BERNIE SANDERS.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I APPRECIATED.
IT’S A TOUGH TIME TO BE A
DEMOCRAT, THAT SUBJECT IS WATERS
WORDS.
TONIGHT, SATURDAY, FEBRUARY 22,
THERE IS NO SCANDAL HANGING OVER
DONALD TRUMP’S HEAD.
BLOOMBERG BLEW IT IN A SOCIALIST
IS RACING TOWARDS NOMINATION.
THE IMPEACHMENT FIELD, SO
DEMOCRATS HAVE TO FACE TRUMP AT
THE BALLOT BOX.
DEMOCRATS KNOW THEY CANNOT BE
HIM SO THEY’RE TRYING TO GET AN
OLD RICH REPUBLICAN TO DO IT.
THE BLOOMBERG SHOW, HE PAID
$400 MILLION, MAYBE HE’S INTO
THAT THING, THAT IS NONE OF MY
BUSINESS.
BUT THAT WAS BRUTAL.
AND NOW HE IS GETTING CLOGGED
ON.
>> THE DEMOCRATIC INCIDENTAL
DEBATEPRESIDENTIALDEBATE IN LAS
>> MICHAEL BLOOMBERG A GLOBAL
PARTISAN WHO SPENT MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TO RUN IN THE RACE.
>> MARJORIE HUNTER MAJORITY
PARSING THE HOUSE PRIORITY OF
BEATING PRESIDENT TRUMP.
JESSE: HE DOES NOT HAVE WHAT IT
TAKES AND HE LOOKS LIKE A MUMMY
UP THERE.
>> I LIKE TO TALK ABOUT WHO WERE
RUNNING AGAINST, A BILLIONAIRE
WHO CALLS A FAT BROAD IN
LESBIANS.
AND NO I’M NOT TALKING ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP, I’M TALKING ABOUT
MAYOR BLOOMBERG.
>> THE MAYOR SAID WE PASSED THE
SIGNATURE PIECE IN THIS
DEMONSTRATION, IT’S A DISGRACE.
>> BERNIE’S EXACT WORDS, LOOK IT
UP.
MR. BLOOMBERG HAD POLICY IN NEW
YORK CITY OF STOP AND FRISK WITH
AFRICAN-AMERICAN AND LATINO
PEOPLE IN AN OUTRAGEOUS WAY,
THAT IS NOT A WAY FOR VOTER
TURNOUT.
>> IT IS DIFFICULT TO SPIN A
DEBATE SO WE GOT THE TRUTH.
>> THE REAL WINNER IN THE DEBATE
LAST NIGHT WAS DONALD TRUMP.
THE PERSON THAT WON THE DEBATE
IS DONALD TRUMP.
>> DONALD TRUMP DESTROYED
MICHAEL BLOOMBERG LAST NIGHT.
>> IT WAS A GREAT NIGHT FOR
DONALD TRUMP, I THOUGHT IT WAS A
TERRIBLE NIGHT FOR THE
DEMOCRATS.
>> I DON’T THINK ANYBODY CAN
WIN.
>> TRUMP WON EVERY DEBATE.
BUT THE INTERNET NEVER LOSES.
[CHEERING]
[INAUDIBLE]
JESSE: PRESIDENT DELIVERED COLOR
COMMENTARY ON WHAT WENT DOWN IN
VEGAS.
>> MINI MIKE DID NOT DO WELL
LAST NIGHT.
I WAS GOING TO SEND HIM A NOTE
SAYING IT IS NOT EASY DOING WHAT
I DO IS IT, HOW ABOUT KLOBUCHAR,
SHE CHOKED.
HE LOOKED AT HER AND SAID
SOMETHING SLIGHTLY DEROGATORY
AND SHE SAID ARE YOU ACCUSING ME
OF BEING DUMB.
THAT WAS THE END OF HER CAMPAIGN
IN MY BOAT.
HOW ABOUT SLEEPY JOE AND HIS
PERFORMANCE.
GREAT TO BE WITH THE GREAT
PEOPLE OF OHIO, NO JOE, YOU’RE
IN IOWA, IOWA.
HE DID IT FIVE TIMES.
YOU’RE GOING TO VOTE FOR ONE OF
THESE PEOPLE COME UP PROBABLY
CRAZY BERNIE HE SEEMS TO BE
LEADING.
JESSE: BESIDES THAT, TRUMP HAS
THE POWER OF THE PRESIDENCY ALL
BEHIND HIM.
HE TOUCHED DOWN AT THE DAYTONA
500 AND AIR FORCE ONE, AMAZING
SPECTACLE, DRIVES THE
PRESIDENTIAL LIMOUSINE, THEY
CALL IT THE BEAST AROUND THE
TRACK AND THEN HE STARTED THE
RACE HIMSELF.
>> DAYTONA INTERNATIONAL
SPEEDWAY WE LOVE OUR COUNTRY AND
IS TRULY AN HONOR TO BE WITH ALL
OF YOU AT THE GREAT AMERICAN
RACE, GENTLEMEN START YOUR
ENGINES.
JESSE: THE MAJESTY OF MOMENTS
LIKE THIS PLUS THE RED-HOT
ECONOMY, THE SHARP TONGUE, IT’S
GONNA MAKE THEM HARD TO BEAT.
BERNIE SANDERS IS A LONG SHOT.
HALF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY HATES
HIM.
BECAUSE HE IS NOT EVEN A
DEMOCRAT.
BUT HE IS SURGING BECAUSE HIS
TROOPS ARE ON A MISSION.
SANDERS AND BERNIE CANNOT BE
CONTROLLED.
THEY ARE A THREAT TO POWERFUL
PEOPLE.
SO POWERFUL PEOPLE ARE NOW
FIGHTING BACK IN THE SHADOWS.
THE CIA BRIEFED BERNIE LAST
MONTH THAT RUSSIANS ARE TRYING
TO BOOST HIS CAMPAIGN.
THEN THE CIA LEAKED TO THE
WASHINGTON POST, THE DAY BEFORE,
BERNIE WAS NOT HAPPY.
>> WHEN WERE YOU BRIEFED ON
THIS?
>> I’M GUESSING A MONTH AGO.
>> A MONTH AGO HOW DO YOU THINK
IT CAME OUT NOW IF YOU HAD A
BRIEFING A MONTH AGO.
>> I’LL LET YOU GUESS, ONE DAY
BEFORE THE NEVADA CAUCUS, WHY DO
YOU THINK IT CAME OUT.
JESSE: SNAKES IN THE INTEL
INDUSTRY ARE DOING BERNIE JUST
LIKE THEY DID TRUMP, WITH THE
RUSSIAN RULERS AND MAKE THEM
SUSPICIOUS.
AT LEAST THEY BRIEFED BERNIE